oh my goodness okay and what is this
lemonade three
dollars and bracelets 10 to 20.
looks like the kardashian kids are
following in their famous mom's
entrepreneurial footsteps i love that on
sunday khloe kardashian hit up her
niece's lemonade slash
jewelry stand and documented the whole
thing on her insta story
so look what i came across
okay what's the sales pitch like tell me
what you're doing here
yep that's kim kardashian's
eight-year-old daughter north
and courtney's nine-year-old daughter
penelope oh my goodness okay
and what is this lemonade three dollars
and bracelets 10 to 20. yeah but they're
handmade by penelope
you guys made this and north yeah
blink and you just might miss court's
six-year-old son brain
too beautiful amazing and if you wanted
a closer look at the merch you're in
luck
coco posted this close-up snap of her
purchase
i love it back in 2017 kim told e.t that
she hopes her four
kiddos whom she shares with her ex kanye
west are inspired by their parents work
ethic
i hope that they just find their own
motivation
and no matter what that is no matter
what they want to do in life i hope that
they
work really hard i think they have good
exam i i learned from seeing both of my
parents work really hard
and i think our kids will see you know
kanye and i work really hard
and i hope that's motivating for them i
think it's safe to say the kids
they are taking note you guys made this
and north
yeah meanwhile kylie jenner spent sunday
in the kitchen with her three-year-old
daughter stormy
the kylie cosmetics founder took to her
insta story to share a step-by-step
guide to making their favorite chocolate
chip cookies
and she had the help of her tiny little
sous chef
all of it baby of course this is hardly
the first time stormy has hit the
kitchen with her famous mom
wow you are such a good helper storm
back in october stormy helped her mom
make some super festive halloween
cookies
are you excited
you were the best typewoman storm or
hype baby
and when christmas rolled around the two
were back at it
what are we baking today storm let me
eat cupcakes
we're making cupcakes yeah yeah they
whipped up some
seriously impressive grinch cupcakes and
stormi showered her mom with
all of the compliments mommy
thank you so much
as for stormy's dad rapper travis scott
a source tells et
quote travis has been really focused on
being around
more and spending a lot more quality
time with both stormy
and kylie he's been very present and he
has been working on having more fluid
communication with kylie to better their
relationship
i love it back in june kylie shared this
family snap alongside the caption quote
happy father's day travis scott one day
isn't enough to honor the dad you are
we are so blessed to have you and that
same month
the family of three took a trip to new
york where they posed on the red carpet
and stormy totally stole the show
source previously told et that kylie and
travis are trying to make things work
travis really respects kylie and
worships the ground she walks on
she means a lot to him he loves that
kylie is such a boss
and how great of a mom she is kylie
loves that travis is so creative and
that he makes a big effort to be
involved in stormy's life
you